Want to know what's heating up theaters this weekend?
I did not start this war.
Apes must defend themselves against an army of angry humans
led by Woody Harrelson in "War for the Planet of the Apes".
It will be a planet of apes.
A teenage girl comes into possession of a magical box that grants wishes,
but extracts a gruesome price in "Wish Upon".
What does it want?
Just soul.
My father bought you.
Sold into an unhappy marriage, a young woman is drawn into a fateful affair in "Lady Macbeth".
Do you love me?
Of course.
Through hell and high water I will follow you.
See what's hot in theaters with this week's Fanticipation.
So what's your weekend ticket going to be? Let us know by commenting. See you next time on weekend ticket.
Go to war with hunger. Counter your craving to get a free movie ticket  to see
"The War for the Planet of the Apes" when you buy a $25 limited-edition gift card. See it in theaters July 14th.
Red Robin... yuhm!